problem that bothers me you says
black lives matter
i've worked here part-time plus i'm a
part owner of this story
you said black lives matter why don't
you choke me i'm black
tell them look what you did to my store
tell them no
not what you said to my store tell them
sister that's my cause i got their back
these are my names right here things
you've done good names
for black lives matter we've been here
all night
cleaning up all night tweeting cause we
got black people man
right here with them black lives matter
you needed money get a job
like i do stop stealing this
is the neighborhood we try to build it
up
and you tan it down
[Music]
hey i'm dave rubin and it's small
business week here on the reuben report
joining me today is mrs
lucy and mustafa al-saheed of
valentine delhi corp of bronx new york
mrs lucia mustafa welcome to the show
thank you we glad to be mrs lucy
i think everybody knows you at this
point um
i know that you probably wish they knew
you under different circumstances but
you just played
the viral video of you so before we do
before we do anything else
can you guys just describe the nature of
your relationship i thought maybe you
guys were partners in the business
exactly but it seems like you're
you're in the midst of figuring out how
you're going to work together with the
deli
yes he's asking you
no he said us so i'm giving you okay
um before before all this
we had a plan to do um a place
for her and and inside the store to do
uh
did she do what do you call it uh well
like mostly
catering sewing and then uh
different little thing baskets that
could be made for
mother's day father's day valentine's
day
uh shirts being printed a lot of
different things
catering also
and then before we we we um
get into it as point as this thing
happen
and then stop us from doing anything so
basically the day
that the riots occurred you guys were
about to start working together
is that right yeah yeah yes fixing the
place up outside there
you start working but they tore it up
what can i do
and now the way that i feel because the
area that we are in i'm afraid to have a
place out there
because uh kids they vandalize and
uh jealousy and and
trifling things going on right now and
i said i'd rather put i told him i said
i want to start my business
in home for right now and then we
look for a bigger place where it can be
catering you also can come in and sit
uh you don't have to be
afraid you know trying to look at your
pocket or look at someone trying to
steal from you or anything like that
one i we sent the video out really not
for the go fund
not me i wasn't thinking about go fund
i was trying to get the bear and all of
their attention in washington
look what's going on look what's going
on
and i was really pissed because we was
about to start
something you know the first time a
black
owned business over here even though
he had his vision minds would have been
separate
but it was up through by him that he
offered out of his pocket to help me
who is going to do that for you my
friend nicole arbour set up the gofundme
for you guys
and let me tell you something yeah miss
lacola is a blessing
okay without her this would have never
happened
even my dream would never come true just
because
i'm starting at home it don't mean that
it's not going to happen
because it's going to happen and i want
everyone to know that
those who gave those who helped
those who stood by me
didn't have to stand by me
my dream of getting this business
and hiring minority peoples in the
neighborhood those that
been affected by this pandemic they went
back
to see if they had a job yeah they don't
have a job
i want to help them come on we got work
to do
and by bringing them in putting their
expertise together
all of us together we could create a
good business
it's not my business but it's the
kingdom business
i want to be a god kingdom builder
and that's my dream and it's going to
happen with the funds or without the
fund
i'm not money hungry and i told you
she's not really
i told them that i'm not money hungry i
don't want your money
i want your prayers but people kept
calling me
saying we believe in you we see your
business too we see your vision
and we like to come and come on be a
part
i want them to know that when this
business come
up their name is going to be on it the
givers
and those who are anonymous that don't
put down their name i want them to know
on that billboard that i want to made up
with every given person who
gave this is your business too
because it wouldn't happen if it wasn't
for me
so i say this and
this is my final thing what happened
that night
god took a bad situation and turn it in
for his glory is good
yes i'm not a king i'm not a king
i'm not a kingdom taker i'm a kingdom
giver that's what i wanted well listen
mrs lucy i said it to you right before
we started recording but i mean
you're a true american hero because this
is what america is all about
something bad happened and you guys are
now
actually bringing people together in the
name of it
it's actually incredible mustafa can you
tell me a little bit
more about now that you guys are getting
some funds and you're trying to rebuild
and you guys are
are there doing this uh how else has the
kind of community come together around
this
and how do you kind of see the future of
working together in your business
that night she was um she was here all
night with us
you know we was um in front of the
business we closed there and just
just out there to make sure nothing
happened to it
and then um they broke into a store next
door
it was a pawn shop and then something
happened
there was fighting and it was a shootout
too like two shots shut
so
so um we said um
to work she's going to work yeah so we
said
you know it's not worth it for anybody
to die for business so we left
and then she was and she was she was
here
like after we left like 10 minutes later
she was in front of the store
and then uh as soon as i got home i'm
looking at the cameras
and then i after she left they started
broken uh
into the store so i know i called i said
mommy they broke into the store and then
she said i'm coming right now so we met
here she was you know
she was she was like you said she's a
hero and
she stopped everybody from here until i
get here with the other worker
um and then um
um she was here all night till the
morning like not not in the morning like
almost afternoon cleaning the glass
helping us to clean the whole store
um she's she's
not and she do stuff without you know
like she said she's not a money hungry
or anything
i had a worker that had uh covered a
corona cover 19 she used to take him to
the hospital
in the middle of the night and stay with
him in the emergency room for hours
and then he tried to give her money she
went crazy she wants
she went she got mad at him you know we
we
you feel like she's she's the mother for
everybody here and
and and the business and then you know i
know for almost
six years now and then we always talked
about doing something together
and then uh it was like a few weeks
before that whole thing happened i was
talking i was telling her because i know
she's special
and now you know she works hard um
and then we talked about doing something
outside for her to do you know
like to do together and then this thing
happened it stopped us from doing
anything
still you know still we just you know
building a little bit by a little bit we
try to get you know
how it was before and and
well you guys you guys are exactly what
america is all about so
before i let you go uh mrs lucy i'm
hearing all sorts of wonderful things
about you when you walked away
uh but if you have one if you have one
message
for for the people right now that are
frustrated that are upset you know that
are protesting that are that are looting
all of these things what would that
message be
stop you blame
this one you blame that when you blame
this one you're pointing fingers stop
point the thing at yourself look
yourself in the mirror
and ask yourself where are you
in this are you to do good
or is it bad i always have said
and i told kids when i was at ps 85 as a
parent involvement task force
let me get you whatever you do be good
at it that's what my dad used to say
he wasn't educated but he had a lot of
wisdom
not only that he said you don't still
work for it and you know
he also used to take me on sunday we
pick up little ballers or little bottles
was two cents
but that was our little candy money and
we had fun
doing it you know it was no problem i've
been working ever since i was four
until i got hurt during 9 11.
go out and do something there's jobs out
there
it may not be a million bucks but don't
give up on your dream look at me i'm
69 years old i'll be 70 this year
and my dreams is coming true don't give
up but don't be taken from people
because when you take from them you took
from yourself
you really do well listen god bless you
guys
i promise you next time i'm in new york
city i'm heading on up to the bronx
and i'm going to check out valentine
deli
and we're going to put links to all your
stuff down below and get you guys some
extra business
and just keep up the good work and just
know that truly millions of people in
this country
are rooting for you guys thank you very
much thank you appreciate everything you
guys doing
but bring heart too because i want to
put my arms around
and i will bring nicole i promise you i
will bring nicole
i can't wait to meet her face-to-face
and tell her thank you
i want to do something for her too so
let her know
you know what done i am gonna i'm gonna
fly her out i'm gonna fly her out myself
we're gonna come to the deli together
okay so i look i look forward to seeing
you guys in person and good luck with
everything
thank you very much thank you thank you
for your time and
for everybody to listen that they dream
can come true
get up off your butt if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell